mathieu lebrun gérant de la discothèque
le milton à saint lô dans la manche
bonsoir avec le brun merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france on imagine
que cette nouvelle ce week end c'est un
vrai coup dur pour votre profession ab
c'est un coup de massue complètement
c'est à dire que avec ce qu'on voit
alors je suis aussi propriétaire d'un
bar et je vois ce qui se passe dans mon
bar et dans tous les bars de frons
actuellement son attention ce n'est pas
une critique on est bien content aussi
que les bars et les restaurants et puis
souvent on pu ouvrir
mais là réellement et ce qu'on a pu voir
aussi joie des images de la fête de la
musique sur paris c'est juste très très
étonnant qu'on ne puisse ouvrir
sachant qu'on a proposé des choses des
mesures qu'on aurait pu mettre en place
en discothèque et là on voit ben en fait
on a déporté le problème c'est à dire
que les discothèques sont fermés mais
par contre toute cette jeunesse qui veut
sortir actuellement et ben vont dans les
bars dans des fêtes sauvages avec aucun
respect où il ya aucune règle et aucun
respect respect des règles le pardon est
donc effectivement mis en danger en plus
ces jeunes je ne vous parle pas des
comas éthyliques et tout ça qu'on peut
retrouver et on sait déjà que la police
et la gendarmerie ont déjà beaucoup de
mal à gérer tout ça sortie des bars et
des fêtes sauvages
on peut imaginer votre désarroi mais
forcément c'est ce qu'on vous lirez
malheureusement ce virus effectivement
sévit particulièrement dans des lieux
confinés au monde ans ouvrière des
échanges de proximité on va dire ça
comme ça qu'est ce que vous répondez
justement voilà pour votre entreprise
mais défense alors moi ce que je vois
alors on est on est réellement si on
doit ouvrir en septembre réellement j'ai
envie de vous dire pourquoi pas mais est
ce que vous connaissez une entreprise
qui est capable de tenir sept mois sans
aucun revenu sans aucune rentrée de
chiffre d'affaires alors juste le
chômage partiel ça s'arrête là et on a
des établissements et en ce moment
pendant qu'on se parle j'ai un de mes
collègues qui attend bretagne 35 la
discothèque le tremplin
mike qui est en train de faire une grève
de la faim et qui ne s'alimente pas en
ou non plus c'est à dire ça dure trois
jours 1 en 3 jours et ils demandent à
rencontrer emmanuel macron afin d'en
parler parce qu'il faut absolument
trouver une solution
samedi rendez vous conte qui nous ont
passé un communiqué de presse en gros
voilà csau vous fermer
restée fermée jusqu'au mois de septembre
même pas un minimum de considération
enfin c'est juste incroyable
qu'est-ce que vous avez justement
proposé comme mesure vous dites voilà on
leur a proposé des choses parce que
encore une fois la distanciation social
en boîte de nuit surtout certaines qui
sont un petit peu confiné c'est
forcément compliqué ni plus ni moins ce
qu'on peut retrouver dans les bars
actuellement c'est à dire on rentre avec
des masques on peut contrôler la
température on sait faire on peut
contrôler les identités à l'entrée est
évidemment quand les gens sont à leur
table ils peuvent enlever le masque
alors on se doute bien qu'avec la soirée
passante
ça va être dix fois difficile à
contrôler mais j'ai envie de vous dire
actuellement on est des professionnels
et on sait le faire et on fera beaucoup
mieux que ce qu'on voit actuellement on
a des agents de sécurité
là dans les bars c'est très rare quand
il ya des agents de sécurité et il n'y a
actuellement en france aucun respect et
c'est ce qu'on voit depuis deux ou trois
semaines et la fête de la musique en est
la preuve
rien n'est gérée actuellement les
professionnels de la nuit on leur a dit
rester fermés terminé pendant ce temps
rouvre les ehpad dans les supermarchés
je vois des gens ont des supermarchés ou
des zones commerciales qui sont remplis
de personnes sans masque sans rien du
tout et nous le dit rester fermés
incompréhension totale
alors vous allez saisir le conseil
d'état
c'est bien ça c'est ça donc les
syndicats ont décidé sous l'impulsion de
l'umih et du génie de saisir le conseil
d'état pour trouver une solution mais
d'autres manières il est important qu'un
an à nos dirigeants je pense à edouard
philippe évidemment et prennent la
parole et une trouver une solution
financière financière parce que nous
sommes actuellement 1610 potec en france
et si on continue comme ça je pense que
ce sera plus de la moitié discothèque au
mois de septembre qui ont disparu avec
les drames qui vont derrière ce que
souvent les gens oublient c'est que
derrière il ya un patron il ya une
famille il ya des crédits il ya toute
une vie parce qu'on est on est on est
comme tout le monde est là sans rentrées
d'argent bon actuellement je vous le dis
depuis mi mars je vis en salaire
heureusement que j'avais un peu d'argent
de côté ils n'essaient pas le cas tout
le monde aujourd'hui est ce qu'il ya
d'autres façons d'autres pistes
peut-être que vous pourriez creuser pour
rentabiliser
les discothèques est ce qu'il ya au
moins une aide au moins de la part de
vos syndicats peut-être les singles on
est on est on est un petit secteur on a
un petit milieu les syndicats ne vont
pas pouvoir payer nos pertes de chiffre
d'affaires nous sommes assurés d
assurance étrangères parce que plus
personne pas beaucoup enfin toutes les
assurances de ne pas assurer les
discothèques et donc effectivement on
parle de se retourner contre les
assurances ou mais je n'y crois pas
personnellement
donc il faut il ya qques da qui peut
nous aider actuellement quand on vous
avez entendu c'était il ya quelques
semaines ce fameux cluster encore et
d'une discothèque justement c'est ce
genre de nouvelles selon vous qui fait
peut-être peur au gouvernement qui sort
évidemment le parapluie forcément
voilà pour se protéger mais aussi pour
protéger de la diffusion de l'épidémie
ça vous le comprenez tout de même
effectivement quand j'ai entendu le
cluster en chine je me suis dit c'est
pas une très bonne nouvelle pour nous
mais ce qui a vraiment mis je pense le
feu aux poudres c'est la sortie
d'olivier temps à l'assemblée nationale
les dernières là pour la semaine
dernière par don pour la prolongation de
l'état d'urgence où on nous a carrément
ont pris pour des renégats des dangereux
enfin c'est incroyable ce qu'il a pu
dire j'ai été personnellement très
touché et pénible et de ce que j'ai pu
entendre
parlant de discothèque de 1500 à 2000
personnes c'est très très rare dans
notre milieu
la moyenne nationale est de 500 est ce
que vous espérez quand même des
assouplissements de mesures notamment
par le sceau vente de cette fois l' état
d'urgence à nos 10 juillet qui va être
levé est ce que c'est un rapport
éventuellement en rapport avec la levée
de ces mesures ont concerné de toute
manière moi je vous le dit directement
les on est en lutte carrément au combat
et on va tout faire pour pouvoir ouvrir
nos établissements le plus rapidement
possible et comme je le dis il ya des
gens qui ont tous doivent certainement
m'écoute et me dire oui mais c'est
dangereux est réellement on est sur une
moyenne d'âge de 25 entre plupart des
clubs en france
donc les gens ne se sont pas touchés par
ce à nos clients il ya des gars très peu
de gens touchés par le vide dans ces
âges et ceux qui ont peur d'aller en
discothèque
il faut tout simple
à venir est ce qui est indécent sera ma
dernière question des exceptions pour
les discothèques en plein air à ce qu'on
peut danser aujourd'hui en plein air si
on sait qu'il ya des discothèques
mollahs qui ont des terrasses ça c'est
possible
il a déjà déjà des aménagements qui ont
été faits pour certaines discothèques y
avait un grand patio on va dire sur
l'extérieur et qui peuvent ouvrir en
mode barre mais ça ouvre déjà sur des
dérives on a déjà des retours ou en fait
la discothèque s'est placé déplace à
l'extérieur et des gens qui dansent sans
qu'aucune distanciation masquer les
compagnies j'ai l'impression quand même
que quand les gens sont serrés est ce
qu'on peut voir les images du canal
saint martin le coc vite va pouvoir se
propager au temps mes pigeons
merci en tout cas mathieu lebrun vous un
petit peu perdues sur la fin mais on
aura compris le message un gérant d'une
discothèque dans la manche merci à vous